buonasera a tutti e benvenuti alla
finale del grande fratello vip
ma bando alle ciance partiamo subito
insomma come sapete i nostri vip hanno
passato più di 320 dentro la casa e
questa sera insieme a voi scopriremo chi
sarà il vincitore o la vincitrice di
questa edizione del grande malato perché
io adoro insomma scoppiettante
fantastica fantasmagorica ma partiamo
subito con una delle terminalista
insomma congiura dell'andis uno dei tre
finaliste e donne che è riuscito appunto
arrivare in finale e giura nome di santi
come ha vissuto questo percorso e
soprattutto che pensi che vincerà il
grande fratello visto come ho detto
prima insomma questo percorso e ne siamo
molto difficile perché mi sono fatta
mille paranal e su andrea e ho sofferto
molto questa lontananza
anche se poi ho capito che in realtà non
dovevo perché sono molto sicura dei suoi
sentimenti e soprattutto dei miei
detto questo avuto una compagna con
quella avventura è stata veramente
fantastica soprano di ciccia e attivi
appena lo scorso che mi stanno perché mi
fa schifo sempre avuto come lo trovate
in serie a letto è però lei un abito
niente ci pensa che sia stato luca
invece lo sai che è stato lo saranno
va bene giura grazie mille insomma come
avete capito
giulia salsicciata moltissimo a ivana
un'altra delle finaliste di e tanto e
ciccia e voleva un punto sapere da
ciccia dei tanti ivana cosa ne pensi
insomma di questa finale e che pensa
comincia lange altri libri garantita ai
pesanti
ciccio c tanti ma che stai facendo che
stai cercando insomma ha allora c'è
problema io non trovare più miopi
pistillo mi ha scritto questo a questa
lettera
se tu vuoi tu pipistrello but to sciupa
altrimenti uccido questo è sequestro
persona a tai chi e stato amore
dimmi chi e stato perche mi ha rubato
unico più piccolo papani ciccia insomma
sta tranquilla sono sicura insomma
salterà fuori questo pipistrello prima o
poi parliamo invece della terza e ultima
finalista di questa edizione sto
parlando di alitalia spica in eccitanti
come sta vivendo questa finale cosa ne
pensi cheryl è stato bellissimo
esperienza veramente meravigliosa io non
mi aspettavo di arrivare in finale
lo ha detto anche prima ma daniele
e stata una sorpresa e vorremmo infatti
ringraziare tutti gli italiani che mi
hanno sempre salvato da tutte quelle
nomination
va bene in amburgo invece parlare con
luca agonisti ni e volevo chiedervi due
cose allora abbiamo tutto come vedi la
tua vita una volta finita
quest'esperienza certo domani e poi in
chi vorresti che vincesse il grande
fratello vip si lei che sono stati tre
mesi avere importanti e c'è una voglia
almeno da parte mia esagerata di tornare
a prendere in mano le redini della mia
vita con lavorare e poter decidere al
cento per cento e chi voglio che vinca
batti le mani schiocca le dita luca sono
tutta la vita va appare luca ormai di
sapere che ha creato il tormentone
dell'estate numero 18
faccio i miei complimenti domani sarà
contattato in diretta disco kharja e a
proposito l'on
appunto volevo sapere cosa ne pensa lui
ton o incidenti e che pensi che c'è da
dire insomma se la questione è che
secondo me ha più probabilità di metri e
fare senza ombra di dubbio el hombre
nella television perché a mio parere ha
un'ottima probabilità di essere la
vincitrice
se invece ti dovessi dire che vorrei che
vincesse ecco mi sentirei di farti due
nomi primo l'onesto inutile spiegare la
motivazione secondo il mio nome perché
se vincessi questo grande fratello vi
potrei trasformarmi della fenice che
risorge dalle ceneri in cui ahimè mi
trovavo prima di entrare qua dentro
e per finire in bellezza insomma ci
manca solo uno dei sei finalisti sopra
landry daniele bossari daniele tu come
ti senti soprattutto a chi dedicheresti
un'eventuale vittoria grazie grande
fratello per questa esperienza che mi
porterò sempre nel cuore
come ho già detto più volte sono un
daniele nuovo e non vedo l'ora di uscire
per poter ricominciare da zero più
carico di prima perché questa è la
verità
io sono un uomo daniele sono rinato e
sicuramente se vincesse sarebbe un
motivo d'orgoglio immenso e dedicherei
la vittoria alle due donne che mi sono
sempre stati vicino sto parlando di
filippa e di stella va bene ma prima di
aprire insomma la busta per il nome del
vincitore della vincitrice di questa
edizione ci diremo a sapere se magari
qualche vip eliminato nelle scorse
puntate insomma ha visto qualcosa da
giungere ho qualcosa da dire insomma che
l'età per esempio rischiano prestiamo
che pensi che pensi di simeri di questa
finale e chi pensi che vinca questo
grande rodallo vip e ma cose viviamo
dire insomma meno maniche venete uscito
da lì dentro perché guarda non te ne
tengono in b1
noi abbiamo tutti quanti se mi chiedi
chi che ha vinto grande fratello vip
vinto io perché sono stata l'unica
regina della casa dove che avesse messo
a nudo e sono stata divina divina perché
il gioco è che il quadro come avevo già
detto in partenza quindi scusami al
ingerita ma grande fratello lo devo in
gheriglio e tributi colta e tic tic ma
viva la sincerità insomma cristiano i
miei complimenti e invece sindacale
panza simonetta inserita anche simona
izzo si monaci santi bayern insomma cosa
posso dire penso che questo grande
fratello vip ci posso vedere come
un'epopea senza i rom ma penso che
chiunque di noi si possa sentire
essenzialmente il vero vincitore del
grande fratello vip che penso che sia
attualmente la rappresentazione
televisiva di quello che insomma
comunemente chiamiamo vita va bene siamo
una grazie per il tuo intervento insomma
cavani scorgeremo appena arrivato alla
frusta mi voglia pirla un ultimo
commento alcuno un carnet di pietro
carmen ognuno sta solo sul cuor della
terra trafitto da un raggio di sole ed è
subito sera
grazie mille cambi di sono fino
all'ultimo secondo ci regali sempre
tantissime emozioni
ci siamo ragazzi è arrivato il momento
il vincitore del grande fratello vi
ris
st.louis